ladies and gentlemen a new poll just
came out shows that a lot of people are
disappointed in President Trump
I can't tell through being sarcastic or
not pretty good crowd this is really
true this just came out a new poll
reveals that only one in four Americans
believe President Trump has actually
drained the swamp however three out of
four Americans believe Trump has peed in
the pool
[Applause]
anything it's come out that the new
Republican health care bill and though
you're excited the new Republican health
care bill will hike premiums by seven
hundred percent for the old and sick
yeah yeah it's not a good sign that the
title of the bill is walk it off grandpa
FAA in the news the FAA is investigating
why a drone appeared in the sky during a
San Diego Padres game yeah authorities
have already ruled out the possibility
that someone wanted to actually watch a
Padres game we're in Kaiser one Padres
fan here they'll write yeah he's the guy
that was trying to sell the Civic
earlier
what acidic Padres go there was
something about the quality of your
answer sir yeah he's gonna wait for me
after the show was over injured I don't
have security uh can't afford it today
today Mark Zuckerberg who dropped out of
Harvard University after his sophomore
year gave a commencement speech to
Harvard's graduating class yeah yeah
Zuckerberg began his speech with hello
suckers you idiots
scandal for the church a bishop has come
under scrutiny for accepting a $100,000
Toyota Landcruiser as a gift
yeah the bishop said I'd get rid of it
but it's a chick magnet man
they are they are thank you thank you
today I just want to mention this is the
10 year anniversary of pornhub for how
this pan is oh it's also the 10 year
anniversary of me going to bed 20
minutes after my wife
I think it works better this way yeah
medical research I like that you're
typing you're not watching something
you're like like what do you write your
term paper think about yeah I'm just so
excited by the girls that I'm tightening
I love your outfit yeah oh I don't put a
lot of thought into the apartment
you